all right uh so yeah first I would like
to thank the organizers this is really
nice wonderful Workshop
sorry and so what I would like to talk
about is how to learn a basis from
certain types of measurements and I'll
explain what it means to learning basis
and I'll sort of try to explain why you
may want to consider such a problem and
how to do it efficiently and this is
Joint work with uh my colleague Lewis
rademach and our student James was who
really did a fantastic job on this
uh okay so
um well let me first uh sort of Briefly
summarize so first I will propose an
algorithmic primitive a hidden basis
recovery I'll give some examples of
where it can be used in some
applications and one of them is new but
I won't have time to really describe the
application to speckle clustering then
I'll I'll
say a few words how to do it
and then I'll talk about analysis and in
particular the perturbation analysis
what may be considered
some sort of non-linear generalization
of the Davis Kahan theorem for matrices
for Matrix perturbations
okay uh so
first let me start by telling you what
what does it mean to recover a hidden
basis so suppose you have an orthonormal
basis E1 am
and it's okay to have a patch so when I
say A basis I
I'm fine with a partial basis for
example even one element for me is a
basis
um
you can Define uh we Define the basis
encoding function for few to be the
following so you take in a product of
your input Vector with each of this
basis element and you apply some
non-linearity to that this G and then
you just sum this up so this is the
basis encoding function
and the third of the Primitive would be
given evaluation access to F and the
gradient of f
to recover the actual basis okay so
that's that's the setting of the problem
that's what's interesting to me
uh
so can you choose the use of can you
decide which you or do you I'll also do
this so typically you assume that uh EI
are unknown that so the problem is to
recover EI and U is just an arbitrary
arbitrary uh arbitrary Vector so
uh yeah you can choose it in principle
you mean something like Active Learning
yeah why not you you can yeah you can do
that uh I guess it depends on your
setting
uh
so okay so that's mg we may or may not
know what J's are you know
uh so you are given access to those
functions so we can assume that given a
u you can compute this function
and typically I'm interested to it
for values of this function on the
sphere
so
we're giving this the question is how to
recover Eis
so why is this an interesting problem
well let me point something out
very very basic so just think about uh
standard spectral analysis of a matrix
right so if you have a matrix you can
write a quadratic Soul let's assuming
symmetric Matrix you write a quadratic
form uau
and you write it in terms of this
argument the composition so if you write
it in this form then F of U this
quadratic form is just equal to sum
Lambda i u in the product a i squared
right that's the spectral theorem and if
you sort of think about going back to
the previous slide this is a basis
encoding function with uh GI just being
Lambda i t squared when the Lambda is a
corresponding eigenvalue 4.
uh Vector e i so you can view uh the
spectral theorem as a special case of
this basis encoding
and in if you have a
this kind of function right what would
be the question of recovering the basis
this is just recovering eigenvectors and
eigenfunctions
so that's uh that's obviously a very
important algorithmic primitive
computing eigen decompositions
a more General case of which recently
people have been quite interested in in
terms of uh specifically applying it to
analyzing uh recovery or recovering
parameters of models and machine
learning is tensor decomposition and
basically what you have if you have a
certain kind of tensor that's rather
special tender you can actually also
write it in terms of basis
encoding function and what you get you
have F of U is equal to Thumb giu in the
product AI with the JIS being w i t to
the force so the basis decomposition
diagonal base is the diagonal tensor
bases decomposition is a special case
of the bef
um a more interesting example which is
well also well known is independent well
I don't know more interesting it's
equally interesting uh in fact this is a
special case of the previous one in a
circumstance is independent component
analysis I am not going to describe what
independent component analysis is
basically if you have a uh some sort of
mixture with independent coordinate the
question is how do you recover it giving
some linear transformation of that uh
distribution and it turns out that you
can recover it by setting a a basis
recording function and if you play with
it you will see that the
basis recording function has a form if
you're using the fourth cumulant it's
something like the force cumulant of
redirections times t to the 4. this
would take a little bit longer to
describe but uh
that's one way to rewrite it and there
are some interesting
um there is a work by sun kakadi when
they provided an algorithm for
estimating parameters of a spherical
gaussian mixture model and uh
it turns out that that can also be
written as a basis
as a basis encoding function sort of
equivalent rewriting
and finally I'll skip this but this is
you can also show that multi-way
spectral clustering is also an example
you can kind of reformulate it in this
form and in fact you can apply it to
practical data with trident
okay so that's kind of the justification
that well perhaps it's an interesting
primitive right because you have a bunch
of interesting things people have done
or some new things which can be
Rewritten in that form
now how do you recover it okay so this
is great this is
perhaps I have convinced you that this
is an interesting problem now what do
you actually do with this well so here
is the algorithm and this is a slightly
simplified algorithm you have to do a
little bit more to prove theoretical
convergence but if you just want to use
it in practice this is actually fine and
what we call gradient iteration so what
you do
you um
to the Fallen you take a point on a
sphere you so we are primarily
interested in the values of that
function on a sphere so you take a point
on a sphere U
and you apply the gradient to it right a
gradient of this function is a vector so
you can if you scale it you can think of
this Vector being another point on a
sphere
so what you do you replace U
by gradient of U that's basically all
there is to it and it kind of may look a
little bit strange and then you repeat
this of course until you get some sort
of convergence or until some sort of
Criterion is satisfied and you may think
this is a little bit strange but
actually if you think about just
ordinary Matrix power iteration and if
you go back to this example when F of U
is just equal to U in the product a u
this becomes a u divided by Norm a u and
that's the standard Matrix power
iteration so this is a generalization of
the power of the you know classical
Matrix power iteration
and in fact you can show that this is
also a generalization for a tensor
iteration which have been used recently
so that's uh that's a kind of algorithm
okay now um
what do you want from this right so you
want this iteration to basically
converge to something which is
you know have
um
there's good properties
and you know you want to somehow bound
the number of iterations
so okay well okay
to say something reasonable about this
if you go back and look at the basis
encoding functions
you need some sort of conditions on GIS
right because you have if you recall let
me just write it down so you can compare
have a few with some over I equals 1 to
m g i
u e i
in a product okay
so in general if you don't have any
conditions on G it's very hard to say
anything specific about this because
well it's not quite an arbitrary
function but it is
certainly a rather large class of
functions so what we need we need
um basically the following we need that
GI of square root of x is strictly
convex on zero and one and it's kind of
a strange condition you may think I'll
explain a little bit where the square
root of x is coming from
and then we need this as a technical
Condition it's not strictly this is not
so important this is the kind of crucial
one
and you can see that all previous
examples satisfies both of those
okay well so suppose I have this then I
can prove the following theorem so under
those assumptions on the conference
functions Ji
the set of e i
plus or minus so there is some sort of
indeterminacy up to side yeah
you had you inner product with au these
GIS were simply quadratic right so GI of
square root X is not strictly that's a
very good point so actually the
classical
spectral theory is a limit case of our
framework it doesn't strictly speaking
satisfy so I should
you know it's not completely correct
right so it's a limit case and you I
actually point out the difference it
makes a difference
because you don't get quite the same
thing in fact well I'll get to it in a
second what the difference is so the
third of EI the hidden basis vectors are
the only local extremists or maximum
aluminum of f on the sphere
and uh
and each one of them so each one of them
is a local extremo and there are no
other local extremer and that is kind of
interesting because this is a
it's a slightly unusual situation right
you have uh you know what you have you
have a
non-convex function but yet you have a
very sort of satisfactory enumeration of
its maximum right usually for non-convex
function that's kind of well anything
goes
but this is uh there is some special
structure to this
okay so that's uh what happens when this
is not strictly convex actually that's
uh to address a question uh well if you
have that this is convex but not
strictly convex then if you think about
what happens for axx
there is only one
local maximum right the rest of eigen
directions are not actually local Maxima
they're only local Maxima in the correct
plane
so that's uh that's what the strict
convexity is important so it's kind of
you can kind of think that it
degenerates and at this point you only
have only one local Maxima here you
actually have M local maximum of the
same as a number of your directions
um okay so now let me explain a little
bit because this is kind of a strange
thing right you have this description
and I would like to point out that there
are lots of other critical points
exponential number actually
um
so here is what we call Hidden convexity
and the idea is the following well
it's kind of uh
a simple idea so suppose you just have a
point on a sphere right then if you take
a square root of each coordinate on a
sphere
you get a point whose coordinate sum to
one right because on the sphere you have
the sum squares of coordinates sums to
one on if you take square roots you get
the sumus one so if you write a vector
as u r u equal x i e i if you write it
in this hidden basis and you apply this
transformation to that vector
then what you have you have a map from
the sphere to the Simplex if you take
the square root of each of the
coordinates
here you can think
in function so suppose I take G of U to
be thumb j i square root of UE I so I'm
taking square roots of this
let's not worry whether it's positive or
negative
this function
is actually very similar to the original
function and you can see that the
maximum of the original function
corresponds to maximum of this function
but now this function is actually convex
on a Simplex because each of G of square
root of x is convex
so now I have this function which is
convex on the simplex
and
and the maximum of this function
corresponds to the maximum of the
original function on the sphere so this
requires a little bit more time over
simplifying slightly but that's
basically the idea
uh now what about local Maxima of convex
functions right it's kind of a strange
thing the local usually people in
complex optimization typically what you
do you take local minimum of convex
function right here I'm saying something
about local maximum but of course local
maximum of convex function on a convex
domain not too bad they uh they take
their maximum value on the extreme
points of the domain if it's a simplex
the extreme points would be just the
ends well whatever you call it vertices
of the simplex
and in this case there's two points
so what you can show is that after this
transformation
the maximum of the function of the
transform function will be at this point
and therefore the maximum of the
original function will also have to be
at this point
now of course you don't actually know
you cannot write your function like this
because this is unknown but what you can
look now you have a correspondence
between the maximum so that's basically
the idea for this result
so that's uh the point that there's a
maximum typically what you do is minimum
on the convex domain that's why you have
actually not a unique minimum of course
but you have
um
well M air Maxima in this case because
they're exactly M vertices
okay so that's uh that is kind of uh
that gives some intuition for this
result why I don't want the local
extreme of half I at this point now what
do you actually do well you you don't
just want to say so once you know this
you already can do something for example
you can run gradient descent but
um
um but um we would like to show
something about this gradient iteration
and it turns out that what you can show
about the graded iteration algorithm is
the following so the first the third of
stable fixed points of gradient
iteration is exactly e i
that's a kind of first result
second a graded iteration
and here you have to you know I'm sort
of cheating a little bit because you
have to do some sort of intelligent
restart
you can recover hidden bases efficiently
and I'll talk a little bit more about
what this means in a second and finally
what you get you get that if j i a
square root of Earth R square root of
tier convex so this is a stronger
condition
when R is bigger than 2 then convergence
of graduate iterations of order are
minus one so for example if you have
cube root so if GI is equal to J of T is
equal to T cubed then the T fruit which
is the third root will be convex well
then uh you get convergence quadratic
convergence so that's much faster than
the typical convergence for matrices
yeah
run this with four vectors and
orthonormalize it every iteration will I
get all of the vectors simultaneously
also normalize uh water data reiteration
factors right I could run this with U1
U2 through u m
simultaneously
normalized right that's how we use
I think
I think you can do something like that I
need to think a little bit but I think
it's quite possible that you would get
the full one but it's a little bit
tricky because you have to do this
restarts
um
yeah so that's the kind of that's the
interesting thing and that was observed
before about tensor actually in the
tensor case that you get super linear
convergence for tensors
uh okay so now let me briefly describe
the the
um perturbation analysis
so first what is the model well the
model here is very simple you just add
some noise to your function and you have
to control so instead of uh taking the
measuring the basis encoding function
you're measuring basis encoding function
plus some e where e is basically your
noise
and you have to control the derivative
base to be able to say anything about
the algorithm and in fact if you want to
analyze it you have to control the
Hessian so that's a kind of condition it
may look pretty restrictive it's
actually not so restrictive in all those
like ICA you can control this in fact we
have a result for ICA for example on a
perturbation stability
and one more thing here too if we want
to have some analysis of the
perturbation we have to quantify
convexity of J of square root of x so
it's not enough to say that this is
convex or strictly convex we basically
have to say well how strictly convex and
there are a couple of ways to do it but
one way is to say that j i of square
root of x prime prime right oops
um
if you know to for convexity it's enough
that this is greater than zero but if
you want to sort of have some sort of
quantification of it you have well to
say more specifically States between
these two monomials and here we have to
build it it's a little bit tricky
because this power can actually so Delta
for example is bigger than zero so this
could be something like x to the minus
one
so to sort of make it simple let's just
say that GI of X just a little bit of x
squared would satisfy this you need you
need a little bit more than x squared
okay well so here is the kind of result
we get so we show that graduate
iteration
recovers
the vectors E1 to M up to error
basically
which is you know in the simplest case
you can imagine that well this depends
on M and it depends on this Delta but
say if
um if my ji is X cubed it's just going
to be m to the one half times Epsilon so
that's the kind of bound that you get so
that basically becomes this for the X
Cube
um well what do we need well we need the
sufficiently small perturbation size so
that's kind of if you compare for
example with Davis cahan right so
remember Davis Kahan you have a matrix
you're adding a perturbation to The
Matrix and you are saying well your
eigen projection Changed by no more than
a certain amount how much well if you
have a perturbation of Epsilon basically
you argument projection
changes by no more than Epsilon over
Lambda when Lambda is eigen Gap now uh
here there is no eigen Gap but there is
well your perturbation size has could be
sufficiently small which is not the case
in Davis so it's kind of
a slightly different type of result but
if you look at the form of this it's
pretty similar to what you get for
matrices
uh okay so that's a perturbation size
and now
um what you can actually show is that
the convergence in some sense fast so
when gamma is uh
so here you see that if actually gamma
is close to zero
so this is the number of iteration and
the number of iteration basically is
some sort of double lock
and plus a constant which I'm hiding you
know various things in this constant but
uh it's basically some sort of double
log of the size of perturbation you need
that many iteration to converge to this
error
and um you can see when gamma is bigger
than zero that basically converges very
fast that's kind of analog of super
linear convergence
and when gamma becomes close to zero
well what is happening this becomes log
base 1 and that's the case of x squared
and you know this becomes infinite
so for in the limit case you actually
don't have this convergence and of
course this is true because you know if
you're just doing power iteration for
matrices you would never recover
other eigenvectors other than the main
one right you would have to pull out
some sort of orthogonology constraint
for that
so that's
um that's what that is so for example if
you just put j i of x equal x Cube the
kind of simple typical case what you
have is block two log two something like
one over Epsilon
so that's that the fast convergence
result okay so maybe I should summarize
uh
so uh
so summary
so first there is a non-linear
non-tensorial generalization of the
classical spectral decomposition
second it's an efficient algorithmic
primitive with some sort of super linear
convergence
and um
we provide theoretical analysis of an
additive perturbation model and kind of
analogs of Davis cahonti bounce and
finally well I think maybe just the kind
of philosophical point so that actually
looks kind of differently on the on what
makes power iteration works right in
some sense in ordinary power iteration
you have some homogeneity which gives
you you get a lot of mileage out of it
in this case there is some sort of
convexity so it's not Unthinkable and
the convexity which is not obvious from
the directly the problem so it's not
Unthinkable that there are maybe many
other problems in which there is some
sort of hidden convexity which make
things work but which is not apparent
when you sort of look at the problem
itself
I'll stop here
complexity pictures didn't assume that
the EI is
so in this case we need them to birth on
the basis or it's a normal basis
orthogonal is just as good
that in your picture it wasn't clear why
you needed
you mean
here
um
you are saying if it's not orthogonal
this may still work
um
yeah because you don't have uh if you
have this is not going to be a correct
map right if another orthogonal way
using the fact that this coefficients
are this is orthogonal right this is
some sort of Pythagorean theorem
but there is there is some trick
actually we can do to deal with
non-orthogonality but not in a general
case and in general you have to assume
that
okay maybe just in interest of time we
stopped there uh just the organizers
when we need to tell you that we still
start at one pretty sharp in this room
okay uh for those who don't know there's
the as businesses this is cool over
there that's very easy to get some food
and very quick and there's also the law
school which is over there okay thanks a
lot
thank you